revolution in der forensischen
spurensuche eine neuartige methode
ermöglicht dass täter anhand von einem
milligramm zu überführen es damit ein
perfekter mord ein perfektes verbrechen
überhaupt noch möglich
jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction
hplc steht für die hochleistungs
flüssigkeits chromatographie diese
methode wird schon seit jahren in der
spurensuche verwendet um die
zusammensetzung von proben zu ermitteln
ein heterogenes gemischt die probe mit
also in seine sozusagen homogenen
einzelteile die stoffe aufgespalten
in der praxis kann man sich das ungefähr
so vorstellen an einem tatort werden ja
jede menge proben genommen
diese werden dann verflüssigt und durch
ein substrat geleitet das ganze läuft
unter extrem hohem druck ab die
einzelnen stoffe erkennt man dann anhand
der zeitlichen differenz zwischen
eintritt und austritt der proben das
heißt alles was zu einem
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkt aus dem
substrat austritt aber zur selben zeit
eingetreten ist ist ein anderer stoff
als laie kann man sich unter hplc
erstmal nicht besonders wii vorstellen
so ist hplc aber eigentlich ganz einfach
zu erklären und damit auch zu verstehen
dieses verständnis brauchen wir nämlich
jetzt und die neue methode zu verstehen
damit hplc kann man noch nicht ganz ein
milliardstel gramm finden untersuchen
hplc hrm es ist ein zusammenschluss zwei
methoden der es ermöglicht milliardstel
gramm aufzuspüren hplc kennen wir
bereits was verbirgt sich aber hinter
hrm es die abkürzung steht für das
hochauflösende massenspektrometer bei
dem massenspektrometer spielt keine
flüssigkeit eine entscheidende rolle
sondern die elektronische ladung der
stoffe
diese werden durch ein physikalisches
feld genauer gesagt durch ein
elektrisches feld geschossen
jetzt kommt wieder die zeit ins spiel
dieses mal geht es um die zurückgelegte
strecke pro zeit also die
geschwindigkeit
anhand dieser können die experten das
gewicht der stoffe bestimmen jetzt
kommen wir von einem physikalischen
fällt das gebiet der chemie mit hilfe
des gewichtes eines stoffes also mit der
masse kann man nämlich die summen formel
berechnen
dadurch ist man aktuell in der lage
spuren in der gewichtsklasse von einem
milliardstel gramm zu finden
das sind 000 000 000 000 000 1 gramm
nach dem komma falls ich mich jetzt
verzählt habe kommen 14 bullen
die hplc hr ms methode ist nicht die
einzige neue art spuren zu finden im
knast berichteten forscher der harvard
school of public health in boston über
eine vorgehensweise die als revolutionär
geld micro stammt von dem griechischen
mikros und bedeutet klein und kleine
organismen so genannte mikroorganismen
geht es den wissenschaftlern den
forschern zufolge sei es nämlich möglich
anhand von bakterien die mund im darm
oder auf der haut zu finden sind
herauszufinden zu welcher person sie
gehören alles was man dafür machen
müsste wäre eine analyse von winzigen
dna stückchen der bakterien hautschuppen
haare oder speichel die man sonst mit
hilfe einer dna analyse untersucht hat
sind damit also nicht mehr einzig allein
an einem tatort zu findende den träger
eines menschen
zitat mikrobielle forensik kann das
mächtigste forensische instrument
seitdem dna-abgleich werden so etwas im
winkelried von der university of
california in davis zurück zur
ausgangsfrage ist ein perfekter mord ein
perfektes verbrechen überhaupt noch
möglich
angesichts der aktuellen möglichkeiten
spuren zu finden scheint ein perfekter
mord beziehungsweise ein perfektes
verbrechen zum glück bald überhaupt
nicht mehr machbar zu sein falls es denn
überhaupt jemals machbar gewesen sein
sollte
kommen wir von davis nach köln in köln
arbeitet der wohl bekannteste deutsche
forensiker dr mark benecke doktor mark
benecke hat unter anderem beim
amerikanischen federal bureau of
investigation also dem fbi eine
ausbildung absolviert neben seiner
arbeit dass kriminalbiologe beschäftigt
er sich mit vielen anderen dingen
er schrieb unter anderem das buch mord
spuren dem buch berichtet er über fälle
und viele weitere sagen wir mal äusserst
spezielle erfahrungen erlebnisse
geschichten und so weiter ihm dabei
zuzuhören wie er sein buch vorliest
macht die ganze sache noch viel
spannender
falls euch das interessiert kommt hier
oben über unseren link zu dem hörbuch
mord spuren
da könnt ihr euch dann einen kostenlosen
probe account erstellen und bekommt das
hörbuch mord spuren kostenlos als
geschenk dazu das hörbuch dauert
übrigens mehr als vier stunden
es ist also wirklich prall gefüllt mit
geschichten der link zum hörbuch findet
ihr auch in der video beschreibung der
link zu unserem blog und zu unserer app
findet ihr auch in der video
beschreibung und hier oben unter diesen
findet ihr denn auch und jetzt habe ich
noch eine frage an euch die mich
wirklich interessiert glaubt ihr dass es
mit diesen methoden überhaupt noch
möglich ist ein so genanntes perfektes
verbrechen zu begehen
also ein verbrechen das nie aufgelöst
werden kann könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen schreibt es uns doch mal
gerne in die kommentare
unter diesem video und dann müsst ihr
euch noch eine schöne restliche woche
bis dann